[Music]
hello everyone it's seven o'clock here
in the uk you are very welcome to spend
your breakfast with us here at sky news
this morning
questions this morning over whether an
entire school class
should have to self-isolate if just one
pupil tests positive
for covid we'll be discussing with the
school's minister nick gibb
who is on the program very shortly plus
a new plea from travel agents to add
more countries to the green list
we're joined by the boss of blue bay
travel and the shadow transport
secretary jim mcmahon
also to come 25 years on gareth
southgate returns to wembley as
england attempt to break their german
hoodoo we'll hear from fans
gearing up for tonight's big game to see
if harry kane
can finally work his magic to harry's
though making the headlines for you
today this one as well brother and i are
recognizing what would have been our
mom's
60th birthday and she'll be so proud of
you all
for living an authentic life with
purpose and with compassion for others
this from a prince with a message from
his mom for young people from him
and his brother it's tuesday the 29th
of june sky news understands ministers
are looking at
alternatives to self-isolation rules in
schools
disgusting condemnation from the
vaccines minister as police investigate
this
incident involving the chief medical
officer chris witte
england prepares to face their most
formidable foe germany but can they put
the heartache of 96
behind them i think you can make these
things as big in your head as you want
really um it's a game of football these
boys have played hundreds of them
yeah but not like this one a decision
day in ireland on whether to delay
lifting lockdown it could be left as the
only country in the
eu to still ban indoor dining we're live
in dublin
and attempting to cool down america's
pacific northwest has been
sweltering under a dangerous and
unprecedented heatwave
with canada recording its all-time
hottest day
and it's pretty warm over northern and
western parks here too where
the best of the sunshine is further
south more in the way of cloud patchy
rain and drizzle
whether it's football or tennis that
you're watching could be a bit grey this
afternoon
all the weather details coming up a
little bit later
good morning a big stress if you're a
parent
is your child having to self-isolate
just because one pupil in that class has
tested positive
for covid90 but could a change be on the
cards
uh we've got some breaking news uh to
bring you tomorrow's here good morning
tell us more morning kay well i
understand that the government are
urgently looking at alternative to this
10-day
self-isolation policy any parent or
teacher will know
that they live the mercy of a phone call
from the school
saying someone in the bubble which can
be a class or an entire year group
has tested positive everyone has to stay
at home for 10 days it's been hugely
disruptive
to children's education and in fact last
week
250 000 children were off school
for this reason the most since schools
reopened
in march and there's a feeling among
ministers that something needs to be
done about it there is actually a pilot
underway in some schools to do daily
testing instead
and we should be getting some results
from that in not too long so that is one
alternative
nothing has been confirmed yet but the
new health secretary
sajid javid was certainly telling mps
yesterday that he had asked his
officials
to take a fresh look at this policy okay
lovely for now thanks so much indeed
let's bring in the school's minister
should we nick give
mr gibb a very good morning to you thank
you for joining us on the programme
this morning so tell us um are we going
to get rid of these
kids having to stay home if one person
in the class tests positive
well we have as your reporter says we
are conducting
trials of daily contact testing as a
possible
alternative to self-isolation what
matters also is that we keep the school
safe and if you go around our schools
you will see
a raft of measures to reduce the
infection rates within schools so
there's
extra hygiene there's staggered breaks
we keep children in bubbles
and there's extra ventilation in in
classrooms too to minimize the risk of
transmission
there are about three percent of uh
students are
self-isolating at the moment um and
that's lower than it was
in the autumn and and it tends to
correlate within
the number of infections in the
community but you know children are
testing at home twice a week it's very
important that families continue to
test their children uh twice a week so
we can identify children who do have
covid
and then they don't come into the school
and spread that that virus
to other children so is that a yes
no we'll look at the results of the
trial and we'll make any decisions we'll
be announced before
uh we make a decision on step four going
forward but
you know we have to do everything we can
to minimize the risk of transmission
of this virus and that's why all those
measures have been taken within schools
to keep to keep children and staff safe
so we'll know by the 19th of july
yes we will and we've also written to
schools
uh yesterday asking to prepare for
two tests to take place on the school
premises as a way of preparing for that
when we come back in september uh what
we're also concerned about is having
more children in school we want children
to be in school that's why schools
opened on 8th of march it's why
we prioritize education so the schools
will be last to close first to open
as we deal with this dreadful virus and
this pandemic
because we do know that children are
better for their well-being for their
uh for their health for their education
by being in schools and again that's why
we have the twice weekly testing and
it's why we have all the raft of
control measures within the school
premises to minimize the risk of
transmission of the virus
um yeah it's not working though is it 93
000 young people have failed to return
to full-time
education after schools reopen their
doors um
what are you going to do about that well
this is an issue that's always worried
us
that's about 30 000 more than you see in
a normal non-pandemic
year these are vulnerable children we
want them in school
when the lockdown occurred in march we
took extra measures to
get schools to talk to the parents of of
those disengaged
children who were not coming into school
schools remained open of course if you
remember
for vulnerable children and the children
of critical workers where we weren't
seeing those families sending their
children into school
uh the school would contact the families
we would work with our regional teams
uh local authority level to again to
talk to those families via
via social workers and so on to help do
everything we can to
encourage those children to to come into
school
uh perhaps extending the school day by
half an hour is that going to happen
from september
well catch up of course is very
important even as early as
june last year uh the prime minister
announced a billion pounds of funding
for catch up for money to schools to
spend as they felt
appropriate to help children to catch up
also the national tutoring program was
introduced
back in june last year and
we've uh earlier in june we announced
another 1.4 billion bringing the total
together with the february announcement
up to over three billion pounds of catch
up
uh and that includes money also to help
uh
to to for teachers to do the to be the
best that they can through extra cpd
and training because we know that the
best catch-up of course k happens
every day in school with children at
school in those classrooms
um but we're also conducting a review uh
right now of the evidence about
extending the school day and
time spent in school to understand how
that would work
how effective it would be uh to if we
were to increase the
the length of the school day okay the
other thing you're looking at is mobile
free
school days i mean schools already have
very robust policies
in place when it comes to the use of
mobiles
they know what they're doing don't they
a number of schools increasing number of
schools are
banning mobile phones from the school
day keeping them out of the classrooms
they are a distraction there is
evidence that that they improve
entertainment particularly
uh children less academic children
do better if they're not distracted by
mobile phones countries like france
banned mobile phones from schools two or
three years ago
and i've always been in favor of banning
mobile phones from the classroom they
also can affect children's
mental health and their well-being
they're continually spending
too much time on the screen in our
uh curriculum on relationship and health
education
uh we you know we ask teachers to teach
children
the importance of rationing the use of
mobile phones so they are spending time
outside
with friends doing their homework
talking to their parents and not always
glued
to their mobile phones so yes we do want
to to ban
mobile phones from the classroom but we
are today
launching a call for evidence to see how
best to implement such a policy
and also other measures we want to take
to ensure that we eliminate
low-level disruption in our classroom
get rid of bullying in our classrooms we
want children to have a happy
safe time at school and building on the
work we've
conducted over the last 10 years to give
teachers more
power more control over the classroom
this is going a step further now to make
sure that every classroom is safe
and a happy place you know the teachers
unions have said that they already do
that so they're not quite sure why
you're
why you're saying that this morning
something that else that you had
said that people that pupils don't need
from the 17th of may was masks
in schools and as a result we've seen
the number of kids that have tested
positive going up and up and up will you
look at that again
come september will kids have to
potentially wear masks when they go back
to school
well first of all increasing uh
numbers of children who are isolating
the three percent i mentioned earlier
is driven mainly by infection rates in
the community there's a correlation
between
the number of children who are asked to
self-isolate because they've come into
contact with somebody
covered and the degree of infection in
the
the community we introduced the face
coverings for pupils in secondary school
classrooms
uh as a temporary measure we reviewed
that over easter
and for may the 17th it's no longer a
recommendation but of course
we do give discretion to directors of
public health around the country
particularly in areas of high infection
rates
to re to reintroduce or to maintain that
recommendation
uh in classrooms and i think in about 60
local authorities
in those high infection rates around the
country that there are recommendations
to continue uh face coverings in
in classrooms but it was a temporary
measure uh and as i said the the the
the issue isn't about infections within
the
school that a huge raft of measures in
place so hygiene ventilation cycle
breaks and so on
to limit the risk of transmission in
schools
this is about transmission in the
community um will you be wearing a mask
after the 19th of july
indoors well
i i wear a mask uh now when uh
when necessary and that's the law
yes and i will um we'll see what is
announced
uh as we move to step four well i spoke
to several of your colleagues over the
last
couple of weeks including george eustis
he says he's not going to wear a mask
after the 19th of july and as you know
the chancellor's also said the same i
just wondered what your view was
my view is that i will adhere to
whatever the guidance is that's
announced
leading up to step four the road map so
even if it's not
um a regulation that you need to wear a
mask you might still wear one
i will wear whatever the recommendations
are the guidances to
to individuals about when and whether
they should wear a face mask
we all have to do everything we can to
to minimize the risk of
transmission uh and um uh but
you know we want the roadmap to be a
one-way journey
we want it to be irreversible and we
will look at the data
and i'm optimistic the way things are
looking at the moment that
the 19th of july will be the step
forward the roadmap
okay um have you seen the video chris
whitty i'm sure you have um
being um assaulted by some
jobs last night um what do you think
should happen to them
and do you think that he should have
some form of protection because he
obviously
is dividing opinion this is the videos
were talking to you what do you think
i think this scene is absolutely
appalling
and i'm sure all your viewers and the
general public
will absolutely condemn the behavior of
these jobs
chris whittie has done a fantastic job
throughout the pandemic in advising the
government of the necessary measures
to keep uh our nhs uh
safe to save lives and he has you know
been a very effective uh chief medical
officer during that
that period and those scenes should not
have happened this is now a matter of
police investigation
and i hope the whole weight of the law
will will come down on
on people that engage in that kind of
behavior
should he be afforded some sort of close
protection
well that is a matter for uh for the
security services and
plan for chris whittie but those scenes
should never have occurred in our
society
absolutely wrong people whatever role
they have in government should be able
to
walk on the street walk through the park
unaccosted by
that kind of behavior it should not
happen in a in a free law abiding
society like ours
have you ever used um a private email
account for government business
all business that i conduct goes through
my
private office the information
commissioner
is clear that any key actions and
decisions are
recorded and that's why all government
action that i
conduct takes place through my private
office how i communicate with my private
office
uh is is through a range of measures
including mostly paper through the
through the red box system
so you've never used a private email
account to carry out government business
well i will talk to my private office
through a range of measures you know
phone text
email but the business government
business is conducted
via the private office so that there is
a record of all
key actions and decisions that are taken
uh
all government action you know all
government business takes place through
that office
um how surprised are you that other
ministers
um are not as fastidious as you when it
comes to
carrying out government business well i
think all ministers do
conduct business through their private
office it's it's
it's how you know
i'm sorry talking about private email
accounts as you know and
as we know uh at least two ministers
in the department of health have used
their private email accounts
well that's a matter for the department
of health and to be able to see what
your opinion is
well the rules are very clear that all
government action
needs to take place through private
offices through through formal channels
so that a record can be kept of those
key decisions and when there are
probably people do of course have
private conversations
uh and the key thing is that those
private conversations are
communicated to the private office so
that they can then be uh
if if necessary recorded as part of the
decision-making process
do you have a cctv camera in your office
yes
no i don't i did ask the question of
course i bet you did i bet you did um
you saw chris bryant yesterday saying
that matt hancock is the stupidest man
on earth um snogging his mistress in
front of a cctv camera it wasn't the
smartest thing to do was it
well look matt hancock has said that he
uh breached the social distancing rules
and as a consequence he felt
that he was had to resign and that's
what happened on
saturday matt hancock has been i think a
very
good health secretary he has managed
this
crisis i think the pandemic crisis
exemplary
and we have kept the nhs safe it hasn't
been overwhelmed in that period
and we have them one of the most
successful vaccination rollouts
in the world with 85 percent of adults
now
having had at least one dose and 60 of
adults having had
two doses so uh i would pay tribute to
matt he
took what he felt was the right decision
to resign
and that decision was accepted by the
prime minister
he also employed his mistress at our
expense
well uh you know i'm a education
minister
uh to be appointed a non-executive
director
there is a process that's uh gone
through with
an appoints appointment commission
commissioner involved i'm sure that that
was the process that happened in the
department of health but i'm not close
enough to all the details
no but she's his mistress and we were
paying her
well what you want from a non-executive
director is their expertise and
experience
and that's what will have been sought in
the department of health but again i'm
not
close enough to to the process to to
know all the details
okay good to talk to you thanks for
joining us on the program this morning
thank you
still to come on the program for you
this morning a deepening crisis leaders
in the travel industry raised the alarm
over kovid's impact on the sector in an
open letter to the chancellor
and transport secretary we'll speak to
the chair of abta
at 7 40. at
five past eight we'll hear from the
shadow transport secretary jim mcmahon
as labour calls on the government to
protect reopening of society
by securing our borders a rivalry for
the ages ahead of tonight's big game
joined by an
england fan who's attended every game
against germany
since 1990 and a germany fan
living here in the uk i wonder how
popular he is today that's coming up at
30.
[Music]
meantime the government here might be
confident it won't have to delay
lifting restrictions from the 19th of
july but in ireland reopening may have
to wait
another two weeks currently restrictions
mean
fully vaccinated people can meet indoors
in private homes if there are no more
than three households involved
this can include unvaccinated people
from one household
restaurants and bars can open for
outdoor service for groups of up to six
people
and gyms leisure centres and pools can
open
for individual training let's get more
now from our island correspondent
stephen murphy who's standing by for us
so stephen
uh it does look as though potentially
ireland might be the only country in the
eu where you can't dine indoors
yeah a bit of an outlier all right yeah
you just went through some of the
restrictions that have been eased and
certainly on a day like today the sun is
out here in dublin if you walk around
the city center here
uh say at lunchtime you're gonna see
crowds and crowds of people sitting
outdoors
uh dining having their lunch having a
few drinks maybe and it'll look like the
place is buzzing but that
belies the fact that every single one of
those pubs restaurants cafes they're
completely empty
inside and they're taking a huge
financial hit so one of the
restrictions that people here have been
looking forward most to being uh
relaxed was next uh monday which is july
the fifth
the return finally of indoor hospitality
groups of six people being able to go
into a pub
or a restaurant but now and we're here
at dublin castle just awaiting
uh the irish cabinet meeting to get
underway now it's looking
increasingly likely that that is going
to be pushed back for at least another
two weeks and possibly even longer the
reason being
the irish government has been given new
uh data new modeling from its team of
scientific advisors that shows
um that if the indoor dining and people
mixing indoors and groups
were to get underway just as the delta
variant is beginning to take hold here
in ireland you could see a scenario
where
possibly you would have an additional 2
000 extra deaths over the summer months
and the infection rates and the hospital
the hospitalization rates
would increase uh by a significant
amount so now despite the fact
that ireland the irish government is
under quite a lot of pressure
from uh the economy from various
business groups and so on to reopen
uh it now looks increasingly likely that
at some stage today we're going to get
an announcement from here from dublin
castle
that that date july 5th would be pushed
back to at least we think july 19th
possibly even further to allow the
vaccination program to continue
we may even see a situation where fully
vaccinated people may be allowed
under uh proposals to then uh be allowed
to
avail of indoor hospitality that would
be the first time here in ireland that
you would see
a situation where you would have that
vaccination bonus i suppose but as you
say okay yeah i mean after greece
reopens indoor
uh hospitality ireland if this happens
will be the only country in the eu where
you can't
dine or have a pint indoors okay thank
you
uh other news for you did you see these
pictures on twitter overnight around a
hundred firefighters called to a serious
fire
near elephant and castle railway station
in south east london look what happened
my goodness me that was yesterday
afternoon london fire service say uh
three commercial units
underneath the railway arches were
affected metropolitan police confirmed
the fire was not believed to be
terror related thank goodness also
making the news for you this morning
after a fifth day of searching
two more bodies have been recovered from
the wreckage of a collapsed building in
florida
bringing the total confirmed death toll
to 11.
more than 150 other people are still
missing last night a twilight vigil
was held to remember the victims in the
town of surfside
in miami can you even begin to imagine
how those people must be feeling
hoping against hope that their loved
ones will be found alive underneath all
of that rubble but as each day passes
less and less likely to happen
an nhs hospital which upgraded the type
of face masks used by staff on kovid 19
wards so a full of up to 100
in hospital acquired coronavirus
infections among those workers
adam brooks hospital in cambridge
upgraded the masks used by staff
oncovit19 wards from fluid resistant
surgical masks
to filtering face piece three resp face
piece three respirators goodness that's
complicated isn't it
with the change uh made in late december
in response to its own
staff testing data
britney spears younger sister has said
she's proud of the pop star for speaking
out against the conservatorship
overseen by their father jamie lynn
spears
commented uh comments mark the first
time a member of the family has spoken
out publicly
in support of britney spears in her
legal battle with jamie lynn saying
she had waited until her sister
testified in court
last week britney spears told the court
the conservatorship had been
abusive if ending the conservatorship is
flying to mars or whatever the hell else
she wants to do to be happy
i support that 100
because i support my sister i love my
sister always have always will
as long as she's happy
so let's keep praying
that's all andy murray has won his first
match back at wimbledon since 2017 he
beat 24th seed
oh goodness you know his name don't you
let me okay i'm gonna get i'm gonna go
for it nicholas
basil ashville in fort thankfully he was
beaten
in four sets but not without a wobble
and said the game had been a mental
battle for him
now prince william and prince harry will
both attend the unveiling of a statue of
their mum diana princess of wales
on thursday the brothers commissioned
the piece to mark what would have been
their mother's 60th birthday speaking
earlier during an online ceremony for
the diana award
the duke of sussex said his mother
believed the youth had the power to
change the world
later this week my brother and i are
recognizing what would have been our
mom's
60th birthday and she would be so proud
of you all
for living an authentic life with
purpose and with compassion for others
our mum believed that young people have
the power to change the world
she believed in your strength because
she saw it day in
and day out and in the faces of young
people exactly like you
she witnessed a boundless enthusiasm and
passion
and i too see those same values shine
through
to ethiopiano where rebel forces in
tigre have moved into the regional
capital of mikhail following the
withdrawal of government troops in a
unilateral
ceasefire let's uh find out more about
that john sparks is
in addis ababa explain it to us john
good morning tell us more
good morning kate this is a dramatic and
a surprising turn in
in what is a really bitter and vicious
conflict in
northern ethiopia it's being fought by
the ethiopian government
and the former leaders of the region of
tigre
and they retook the capital at mckele
yesterday after a week of really fierce
fighting ethiopian soldiers federal
police interim government officials
they fled the city and the national
government as you say has declared a
unilateral six-month ceasefire
it's a real setback for the ethiopian
government it's embarrassing as well
the ethiopian prime minister abi ahmed
said last year that this conflict was
essentially over there was just some
mopping up to do
but that clearly is not the case the
tplf they have
released a statement this morning
there's no talk in their statement
about any ceasefire in fact it reads
like they mean to go on
they say to gray will indeed become a
graveyard of the unjust and
unholy coalition of invading forces but
i think a really key question is this
what happens to the citizens on the
ground in tigre because they have
suffered horribly
thousands of people have been killed
more than 2 million people have been
displaced there
is a famine in the region says the un
and there are allegations of
mass killings and mass rape as well and
i am not sure
how this shift in the conflict will
necessarily help them and they certainly
need help
okay for now thank you quick look at
what's happening
actually we're going to go let me just
tell you what's going to happen as far
as the football is concerned 5 o'clock
tonight joe is standing by for us as you
can see what's the weather going to do
for uh
for us this afternoon at wembley joe
good morning
hello good morning to you it's uh
looking a little bit gray has to be said
um
however we've seen these very unsettled
conditions in the south over the past
few days down to an area of low pressure
and that is now pulling away so even
though we've got the cloud
and we may see a little bit of patchy
rain particularly on the way to the
match
it should end up being dry at the end
let's take a look at the weather details
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
hello there good morning yes whether
it's wembley or wimbledon both of them
looking to be rather overcast today
chance of some patchy rain but the
emphasis very much
more on drier conditions than we've seen
in the past few days
and pretty lovely over parts of the
north scotland northern ireland
northern england seeing some lovely
sunshine and temperatures similar to
yesterday
24 or 25 degrees celsius that's 77
degrees fahrenheit
but it is still rather gloomy in these
southern areas outbreaks of rain at
times very mild muggy close weather
through the course of the morning we
could see the clouds sitting and
breaking in some parts but while we do
get any brightness
we're also likely to see some showers
developing so always best of the weather
up towards the northwest
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
as i was saying one of football's great
rivalries set to play out tonight you
know that already didn't you
england take on germany at wembley in
front of 45
000 fans uh it comes after world
champions france were knocked out of
euro 2020 last night
after losing 5-4 in a tense penalty
shootout
oh please don't let it be penalties
tonight they lost to
switzerland it looks as though they were
quite pleased afterwards the swiss of
course
after winning the world cup in 2018 the
french were the favorites to win the
euros
but switzerland will now go through to
face spain
in the quarter-finals becky cottrell
joining us
uh from wembley oh no she isn't at
wembley at all is she she's in
birmingham hello to you
becky what's going on behind you there
looks great fun
yeah talk about anticipation ahead of
the game if you come down to the kirby
estate in south east london
this is what you will find just look at
all these flags
of st george clearly a patriotic bunch
now as you say this is a huge game for
england tonight the next chapter in
their long standing
football rivalry with germany england
haven't won
a knockout game against the germans
since 1966
when they won the world cup final at
wembley and for manager
gareth southgate tonight will be an
historical moment
he was part of the england lineup in the
euro semi-final
in 96 and he missed a crucial penalty
that meant his side
were out of the tournament so the
pressure is on but he says he doesn't
want his team to be rattled
i think you can make these things as big
in your head as you want really
it's a game of football these boys have
played hundreds of them
um there is of course great excitement
uh with uh with fans and
people tuning into the game um but we've
got to trust in
the way we prepare
yes so the pressure is on and that
preparation that southgate was talking
about that will of course
include prep for a penalty shootout if
it
comes to that now whoever wins tonight
will go on to the quarterfinal
on saturday in rome where they will face
sweden or ukraine
back to uk okay lovely that's fantastic
i think you need to go knock on some
doors there becky and uh we'll catch up
with you a bit later on
joining us snp's westminster leader ian
blackford now i don't want to rub it in
mr blackford but uh i wonder
who you might be supporting tonight
i'm just looking forward to all the
support that were seen on on television
came
you almost you almost don't know where
to look because you've got the tennis on
one side the football on another
you know i think everyone's really been
lifted by the spectacle of the european
championships the games have been
fantastic and i
hope we have a good game tonight i hope
you all enjoy yourselves you get what
you get what you wish for as well you
know
scotland enjoyed being in the european
championships we're out and i hope
everyone has that kind of joy and
passion that
that we've had and i wish him wind all
the best tonight oh that's what we were
looking for and and you know you held us
to a draw at wembley well done um
scotland maybe
better luck next it was a good game it
was a good day but it was exciting
and by the way it's good to see you back
here that's very kind of you thank you
mr platford you've got an urgent
question
before the game tonight haven't you um
of the government and its emergency
coveyed contracts what's your argument
well basically what we know is that the
government has spent 560 000 pounds of
our money
uk governments have spent taxpayers
funds on campaigning for the union in
the middle of a
covert crisis money that should have
been spent on covid and the only reason
that we know this
as it's come out through court papers so
this is really a
a rather serious matter i've asked for
an investigation into i've asked for the
government to
reveal the details of their own polling
560 000 pounds on polling
on the union is really quite a sum of
money to spend so
i think the government's got to come
clean the prime minister's got to come
clean
and michael govard of course who was
responsible for this but this is this is
not a good look about a government
that's doing things in a
sleeker way in an underhand way let's
have some transparency let's have some
openness and have some honesty in
politics
are you just attacking the government
for the sake of it and playing the
independence card again
no i'm not because it's the government
that's uh
campaigning against scottish
independence by using public money
in the middle of a pandemic uh against
our interests and if they're spending
public money on this
there is a matter as to whether or not
this is within the law but certainly
what the government should be doing is
letting the rest of us see the
evidence as to what they've uncovered
have you ever used a private email for
government business
i'm not in government but certainly when
it comes to parliamentary business i use
my parliamentary email for all
parliamentary business i would never
dream
of using any other platform whether that
would be other email addresses or any
social media platforms in fact i'm
always very clear with constituents that
any parliamentary business should go
through my parliamentary account
that's the right thing to do we're held
accountable we're held up into
scrutiny as it should be and that should
be exactly the same
for every government minister you were
quite right to pick me up for that i
meant parliamentary forgive me um
do you have um cctv in your office
no not that i'm aware of and of course
the house authorities have been in touch
with all mps
uh overnight to reassure them of course
there's cctv as there should be
in the houses of parliament but not in
the offices of parliamentarians
um i wonder if you might want to comment
on what chris bryant said about matt
hancock in the house of commons
yesterday saying he was the stupidest
man on earth
well look at the end of the day he's
been he's been caught out and i think
people are right i think most
importantly
people were really angered by his
behavior uh of course everyone's
entitled to
our private life but the fact is that
this is a minister that's been telling
people in england in particular is that
how they should behave
people in the main have gone by the
rules and yet again we have a senior
figure in government the architect of
much
of the rules just as we found with the
the coming situation last year has
refused to
behave in an appropriate manner and of
course it's not just about
whether or not matt hancock is stupid
the prime minister seems to have made
comments about him in the past as well
but knowing that he was in the wrong
knowing of his public anger
the prime minister didn't force them out
of office as he should have done
and i think really a lot of this is
about the judgment of the prime minister
not recognizing the
scale of the anger that is there but
also suggesting that matt hancock
could come back into government at some
point this is a prime minister that
really doesn't seem to understand how
the
public feel about these matters but is
it is it the social distancing issue
that that is troubling you uh more mr
blackfoot or is it the fact that he
um employed someone um who was his
mistress
that the taxpayer was paying for
yeah there are there are serious issues
around that there's a number of
questions that have to be answered but
look at the end of the day all of us
need to have confidence in the public
health messaging
and for the person that was responsible
for much of the messaging to be behaving
in such a way
to undermine the rules to undermine
faith and trust and what we should all
be doing
and what is a difficult time we all want
to get through this we all want to get
to a position of safety my goodness
delighted so many people are going to
the football tonight at wembley but all
of us need to make sure
that we follow the rules we follow the
guidance and more importantly
that we follow the law when we're asked
to do so um and
just as far as scottish schools are
concerned was talking about uh english
schools a bit earlier on england wales
scottish schools um
open in august i think they're they've
already broken up haven't they their
kids in scotland
um are you scrapping the 10-day
isolation rule for school children when
they come back
i think these are matters that the
scottish government is is looking at
everybody wants to get a situation
where people can have their freedoms but
of course within all of that
the school children can get the
education that they deserve we want to
get back to normal
but we have to do that in a way that
protects the health of the public as
well okay
i think we're making great progress
albeit of course there is some concern
about the
level of the spread of the virus but
there's a real job to be done to make
sure that we can get this under control
we get people back to
normal as soon as we can but from a
position of safety and as far as chris
whittie is concerned i'm sure you've
seen the pictures overnight mrs beckford
of what happened
to him he was basically assaulted by
some thugs
uh in the park while another one of them
filmed it
obviously it's a police investigation do
you think that he
should have some form of protection
well i think regrettably we need to make
sure that whether it's chris whitley or
anybody else and
his position that's really done an
outstanding job of giving leadership
over the course of the last 15 months it
really is
reprehensible what has happened of
course we saw the pictures just a few
days ago of
one of your colleague journalists nick
what being attacked by a bunch of thugs
as well
this is something that could that should
concern all of us and i'm calling on
politicians
right across the divide to make it clear
that this kind of behavior this kind of
thuggery
is not acceptable that people have to be
held to account i am concerned about the
overall
discourse in public life k about what
happens in social media in particular
we need to raise our game and we need to
make sure that chris whittie and
everybody else as they go about their
business
they can do that in a position of safety
just before i let you go um can people
in the north west my um
home part of the country has come up to
scotland again now or not
well you know that there are some
restrictions at the
at the moment came and always want to
get a situation where
these restrictions aren't there i can
tell you that having come down from the
highlands yesterday there are
thousands if not hundreds of thousands
of people that are visiting from from
south of the border they're all very
welcome
and we need to make sure that people
from your part of the of the world from
the northwest of england can get
get back to scotland as as soon as
possible as well fantastic place it is
to visit too
it's good to talk to you thanks so much
indeed for joining us thank you
my pleasure thank you thank you
tomorrow's with us this morning good
morning lots to talk about tomorrow
okay yes there certainly is i think
schools is the key the key one we now
know
that the government is looking at
alternatives to this self-isolation
policy which is causing such havoc
for parents and teachers with children
waiting for a call to say someone in
their bubble
has tested positive so the whole class
or the whole year group has to be
off and we heard from nick gibb that
daily testing is being looked at
as a possible alternative although the
government isn't confirming anything
at the moment 250 000 children off
school at the moment
now this is what i had to say we are
conducting
trials of possible
alternative to self-isolation what
matters also is that we keep the school
safe and if you go around our schools
you will see
a raft of measures to reduce the
infection rates within schools so
there's
extra hygiene there's staggered breaks
we keep children in bubbles
and there's extra ventilation in in
classrooms too to minimize the risk of
transmission
there are about three percent of uh
students are
self-isolating at the moment um and
that's lower than it was in the autumn
it's very important that families
continue to
test their children twice a week so we
can identify children who do have covid
and then they don't come into the school
and spread that that virus
to other children that was mr gibbs
speaking to us earlier um he also had a
view
on what happened to chris whittie last
night yes chris whitty the chief medical
officer was
filmed his film was uploaded to social
media being
harassed essentially by by two young men
the police are now
investigating that he was walking around
in westminster
and they followed him and we've already
heard from the health secretary actually
saying he thought the video was
completely
unacceptable and the men behaved in a
disgraceful way
this is what the minister nick gibb had
to tell us about about chris whitty
i'm sure all your viewers and the
general public
will absolutely condemn the behavior of
these jobs
chris whittie has done a fantastic job
uh
throughout the pandemic in advising the
government of the necessary measures
to keep our nhs uh
safe to save lives and he has you know
been a very effective
uh chief medical officer during that
that period and those scenes should not
have happened this is now a matter of
police investigation
and i hope the whole weight of the law
will will come down on
on people that engage in that kind of
behavior
so general shocked reaction to this
video questions also about whether
the chief medical officer should get
some form of security now that is not
just ended
to very many uh people just the prime
minister and a handful of members of the
cabinet not every single one of them
based on an assessment but given his
prominence over the last year and a half
he's one of the most familiar
faces of the pandemic there are calls
for that to happen indeed let's see what
happens for now tomorrow thanks very
much thanks a lot
talking about that throughout the course
of the morning of course um meantime
the travel association abta has this
morning written an open letter to the
chancellor
and also to the transport secretary
urging the government for
more support for the sector as it
continues to struggle under covered
restrictions uh joining us is aleister
rowland the chair of after and group ceo
of blue bay travel hello to you good
morning thanks for joining us on the
program this morning what have you said
in the letter
well we've asked for a number of things
and it's not the first time okay that
we've been talking to government we've
constantly talked to government since
march 2000 but
you know travel was the first into the
pandemic to have
serious issues it's been locked down
uh costs are now starting to increase
particularly travel agents and smaller
tour operators
have no cash so we're we're asking for a
number of things
an immediate review of the traffic light
system more countries
added where we feel that they are safe
to introduce the rule the government are
talking about in terms of removing
self-isolation from
amber countries and to remove the
advisory
from the countries and and a tailored
package of support
because outbound tourism has not been
recognized really
at all from government where it will be
the
uh the business that is uh last to
recover in this pandemic
okay um just how badly affected has it
been what's
can we talk numbers yeah i think
we the sector has lost around 5000
heads per month since march
we think that there's around half a
million uh
people employed in the sector we think
there's
just under 200 000 k that jobs at risk
or
have already gone so we are talking
about
really serious issues in the you know
there'll be
no travel agencies and tour operators in
the recovery which is such a shame
because
the uk's tourism industry is one of the
best in the world
it accounts for two percent of gdp and
government need it for the economic
recovery we just need to be
recognized for the support that it julie
should receive
and what happens if alistair you miss
out on another
summer of holidays
i think you know the the market makes
most of its money
over a 12-week period in the summer and
agencies are out of cash they haven't
been able to use furlough because
they've had to look after you know
consumers bookings so people have had to
work
and there's no cash left so you know
the agencies are having to support the
cost of furlough and business rates
relief as that's introduced
and you know businesses will fail
significant
numbers of businesses will fail
thousands um
and as far as the traffic light system
is concerned
how well has that worked i know that you
would you will say
that you wanted more countries to be on
the green list but has it helped at all
with the amber list being there because
labour said they shouldn't be there at
all it should be green list red list
nothing more yes well
there's a lot of logic to that so you
know we worked as an industry with the
global travel task force to create the
traffic light system
but government didn't operate it the way
it was designed otherwise
portugal wouldn't have happened and now
there is an extension to the green list
they're immediately on the green watch
list so for consumer confidence
you know customers really don't
understand
what they can do or can't do and the
testing requirements
so actually it you know more confusion
generally
it you know equals less bookings because
customers just think that it's too
difficult and they don't fully
understand
okay um final thought before i let you
go uh what response have you had so far
as far as the letter is concerned do you
feel that it it that the government
is more willing to listen to you know
absurd pushed really hard consistently
uh we struggle with a lack of ministry
in government
and you know dft support transport so
support
airlines but not the broader industry so
the travel industry generally has really
struggled
to gain any kind of support or traction
with government and we
really hope this open letter is the
start of the change of that so we can
save this great industry of ours
okay it's good to talk to you thank you
very much indeed for joining us on the
program this morning appreciate it thank
you
um i don't know if you've seen the video
this morning of chris whitty being
assaulted
in the street uh we'll show that to you
in just a moment or two in fact here it
is
now he was assaulted by two men
in the street filmed by another the
police are investigating we've heard
from uh sajid javid who is the health
secretary
within uh the last few moments he says
i've seen the video
of chris whittie being harassed it's
appalling and totally unacceptable
the um chris whitty works tirelessly on
behalf of the country we will not
tolerate this sort of behavior towards
our public servants the men behaving in
this disgraceful way
should be ashamed more than that i think
you can see them quite clearly i'm
guessing
that the police will have something to
say about that chris whittie
being accosted and assaulted as he
minded his own business
walking around uh westminster that looks
actually so it's the mall that he's
crossing
there with perhaps saint jensen's part
behind him but certainly i'm sure that
the police
in fact there was a police van there did
you see that did you see that there's a
police vehicle in the back of that shot
that's um something that we'll be
looking at in a bit more detail
hmm fewer than one percent of gcse
students in
england study a book written by a
non-white author in english literature
lessons that's according to new research
by penguin
and the runnymede trust which paints a
stark portrait of the
under-representation of authors from
ethnically diverse backgrounds in the
classroom
shingi mariaki has more for us
at this school in south london the
bookshelves are changing
after a year of discussions about race
culture and identity
the english curriculum has been
overhauled the goal behind this new
chapter
to empower the students when i took on
the role this was just after
the murder of george floyd and there
were lots of conversations about race
and change and while
i didn't go onto the streets of protest
one of the things i try and do every
time
there is an uprising is to think about
how i can bring that into my classroom
how can i remind my students that their
lives matter every single day
according to new research this teacher's
approach is unusual
with the national picture a very
different one a survey by the runnymede
trust in partnership with penguin
found 82 of young people in england did
not recall ever studying a book by a
black
asian or minority ethnic author while at
gcse
one percent of students studied a book
by a writer of color
and just seven percent read books by
woman
students here say there are benefits to
reading books that reflect their reality
alongside the classics that make up the
canon i love the literature
i love the shakespeare but there's i
also loved alice walker
i also want my heritage to be shown in
literature i'm fortunate
that i go to school like this because i
still
feel connected if we want the younger
kids to
actually take an interest in these
subjects it has to be tailored to them
we can't really tailor what a young
child should read to
what you know a group of 50 year old
middle class uh white old men think
would be appropriate this author says
some of the inspiration for his book
based on growing up gay in a muslim
household
came from a text he read in his school
days i remember when i was
doing my english gcse there's this one
poem called presence from my aunt in
pakistan
and it was the first time anyone had
ever articulated
the sense that i felt of being too
english for pakistanis for my pakistani
cousins in pakistan but also
two pakistanis for english society
reading about places and people closer
to home could spark the imagination of a
new generation of talent
shinki maruike sky news
a heatwave has been sweeping across
america's pacific
northwest crews have battled raging
bushfires in california
as the united states west coast and
northwest regions continue
to experience an unprecedented heat wave
temperatures hit a record of 46 degrees
in portland oregon on monday
despite the average temperature for june
being around half of that
and canadians have been attempting to
cool off after the country recorded its
hottest ever temperature
46.6 degrees beating the previous high
of 45 celsius set in 1937. that was a
long time ago wasn't it
australia now where perth and brisbane
have followed sydney and darwin in
introducing snap lockdowns as
authorities struggle to contain
outbreaks of the delta variant of
coronavirus
joining us now professor michael tool is
an epidemiologist at the medical
research institute
the bernard institute he joins us as i
said hello to you professor thank you
for joining us
one of the challenges that australia
faces now is that i think only like
four percent of the population have been
vaccinated haven't they
good morning okay although the sun's
going down here
um because we're finding ourselves in a
very um
different situation than we were just
two weeks ago
um over the last 12 months or almost
since october last year
we've had more or less zero community
transmission of the coronavirus
we have had some outbreaks but they were
always in just one specific
city or state and that state government
controlled them relatively quickly
but today as you said we have four major
cities
in lockdown and three others
with additional restrictions some
mandated
mask wearing so we really
haven't been here before and we are very
vulnerable in fact there are
three um issues that make this
a kind of perfect storm for australia as
you said a very
low vaccination rate only four percent
we have a hotel quarantine system
that now leaks um regularly
on average every week so that someone
who has returned from overseas has spent
days in quarantine has somehow spread
the virus to the staff
or other guests and then it's gone out
into the community
and of course the third issue is the
delta variant which is spreading very
quickly
uh it certainly is in fact i think
there's the issues there was a
hairdresser's in double bay where 900
clients potentially
um have got covered a birthday party in
sydney
similar issues there but as i said
there's only about four percent of the
population that has been vaccinated
so does that what can the authorities do
to try to contain this
well it's going to be very difficult in
the coming months which of course
coincide with our winter
we just don't have enough vaccine we do
produce
astrazeneca here in melbourne um but as
you know
um this vaccine's been associated with
rare clotting events and it's now only
recommended for people over 60.
that leaves us with a single vaccine
pfaser
and we simply don't have enough to ramp
up
um the vaccination of the community
things will get better in our spring
your autumn in october
uh when we will receive a lot more fish
we will get modern
and we'll probably get the newest
vaccine novavax
so meantime during the winter to prevent
further lockdowns like this there's only
one thing
the government can do and that is to fix
hotel quarantine
um we're a federation
and each state runs their own business
but
the federal government does have
authority under the constitution
to basically to to make sure that this
quarantine system
is effective so they could use that
authority to bring
all the states and territories together
and come up with what i call a national
code of practice
that recognizes how the virus escapes
inside these quarantine hotels and
that's usually through airborne
transmission
someone opens their door to pick up
their meal at the same time as someone
else does it
and the virus spreads and it may go to
staff and then out
into the community so even though our
numbers
are very low by other standards we only
reported 25 new cases today
whereas in the uk i think it was 23 000
but because of that low vaccination we
are still very vulnerable
and this variant as you know in your
country
can spread extremely quickly indeed so
we certainly do are there any lessons to
be learned you think from the way
that the uk is trying to deal with the
delta variant for the government in
australia
well i think there's two things we can
learn from the uk at the moment and
one of course is in hindsight we we
should have
not been so complacent last year and we
gone in and and ordered a basket of
vaccines not just
two because we can't fix that now
um but i guess as i said
in another three months we might be in a
better place
um what else can we learn i think um
you know testing i just saw that you're
going to test in schools
i think our schools are not well
prepared
um when there is a lockdown most time
most times we close schools but i think
we have to be better
prepared okay professor sadly we are out
of time but a fascinating insight thank
you so much for taking the time to join
us and good evening to you where you are
thank you
yes thank you kay uh outbreak so the
delta variant
in australia and an appalling video stay
tuned for more here on